(upbeat music)
"notification pop up sounds"
- You said your calculator
died mid-test right?
- Yeah.
- I think you should
move to the back then.
(high pitched clicks)
- Is everybody here going to
college? Not going to college?
- Oh yeah.
- Like what's the deal?
I'm going to college.
- I'm going to college.
- Going to college.
- I'm in college.
- I'm going to college.
- I'm Going to college.
- [Man] Your mom goes to college.
(people laugh)
- When you guys applied to college,
did you submit your score?
- Oh.
- That's it was mandatory for us
- Did
- Didn't submitted.
- I feel like if you submitted,
you should move to that side.
I like a little bit that way.
Yeah.
- Okay. You said you submitted right?
- I submitted, yeah.
- Okay.
- But also like I feel like it depends
so much on the college.
- And you submitted has
also come down here as well.
Anybody else?
- I'm, I'm just thinking
like if you submitted
then you had something to submit.
- Yeah.
- What are we gonna study?
- I'm trying to study
engineering but technically I'm
undecided right now.
- I'm computer science.
- I'm bio-chem, but right
now I'm taking science.
- I'm political science.
- I'm with communications
and media studies.
- I'm pre-med, I don't know.
- Pre-med?
- Yeah
- I'm doing also computer
science and maybe like art.
- I am neuroscience pre-med as well.
- Oh wow.
- Okay.
- Okay. Neuroscience.
- I'm the only liberal arts major.
- You're doing the same.
- I feel like a lot of the SAT
was like more test strategy
than just like intelligence.
- Yeah.
- So I feel like maybe taking AP,
like AP classes kinda help you prepare?
- Yeah.
- So I took nine but that was the max.
- Oh wow.
- Dang.
- I took six.
- I only took three.
- Five.
- I think I took seven.
- I took 13.
- What?
- Move
(everyone laughs)
- 15, aye.
- I took five.
I took five, so you go this way as well.
- I also, I don't.
- GPAs maybe.
- Yeah, that's a good one.
- Also. I also think you
should come this way.
- Come to, actually come up.
How far?
- Nine. And you're a CS major.
- Got you.
- Well me and Emily, we're twins so
(everyone laughs)
- So we went to the same high school
and I'd say our school
had a pretty good emphasis
on taking a SAT and doing well.
- Yeah. I'd also say that,
that our school valued being
like well rounded so
they didn't just like,
for us, valedictorian. I was
salutatorian like right under.
- Well congratulations.
- Thank, not to flex, but uh
- I feel like you should
like move up then.
(everyone talks)
- Probably get like next to your twin.
- Yeah. Okay.
- And you said your calculator
died mid test right?
- Yeah
- I introduced that but I didn't wanna.
- I think you should
move to the back then.
- Yeah, I, okay. Well.
- But I think you can
still do well though.
Cause like math is just part of it.
- Okay, well for my,
- That's half of it.
- But there's like no calculator
and then there's calculator.
- Yeah. And then no calculator
is 500 of the 800 points.
- Oh really?
I'm done with that.
- Do you two wanna switch?
- Sure. Yeah that's fine.
Okay.
- Maybe we should talk about
how many times we took the SAT?
Oh yeah, that's not,
- Might help
- That's really good.
- I took it once.
- Yeah it once, done.
- I only took it more than one.
- I thing I took it twice.
- I took it twice at well.
- So no one's like crazy or anything?
- No. No.
- Maybe.
- You guys got me.
- You'd have to take it like seven times.
- Yeah. Yeah.
If she took it.
- Yeah, I only took it once.
- He took it twice cuz I feel like
then he like might know it.
- Yeah, improve the score.
(melon coly music)
- I have test anxiety and
I'm also neuro divergent.
so I like every board I check off.
I can't really like sit
down and take tests.
I can't. I like freak out.
I don't think that the
score that I got really
reflects my intelligence
because of the situations
that put me into it. I don't think
that's how like my intelligence
really shines through.
- I feel like I'm in the same boat.
I really think the SAT is
not a good measurement.
I don't think the SAT
reflects well on my IQ
or just how well I
could perform in school.
- I have a diagnosed
ADHD. So, uh, taking tests
and just kind of sitting
and just being focused
on that was honestly really hard for me.
I was diagnosed when I was like six.
I would like ask my friends
you know like hey do you guys wanna
like study like at lunch or something?
Cuz if it weren't for that,
I literally would get no help
and I probably either
wouldn't have taken the SAT
or I would've failed it.
- I have ADHD as well, so
like for me, sometimes I'll
sometimes I'll sit there
and like stare at the words
and I'm like
- Yeah.
- Oh my god.
- Like reread the question.
- My brain is just like,
not like, it like freezes.
- When you go to college,
you're going to have
four hour long midterms.
I feel like a four hour long test is
at least somewhat of a good indicator
on how you might perform
in those settings.
- I mean I get that but
I'm in college right now
and the score that I
got on SAT would kind of
show that I'll be at
least decent in college.
But then I got there and I
failed like my first ever class.
- I feel like maybe you guys at the end
should switch. Just based on
like how you value the SAT.
- Yeah, that's, this is a good question.
How do you guys think you
did personally on the SAT?
- I don't know how you feel
but I feel like both of
us could have done better.
- Yeah
- I was pretty satisfied actually.
(girls laugh)
- My bad.
(everyone laughs)
- What was your guys' GPAs?
- Weighted, mine was like a 4.15.
- 3.8. Like seven or so.
- I graduated with 4.2 weighted.
- Four six
- Weighted. I had like a 4 4
- 4 8.
- So I graduated with
a 4 4 I'm pretty sure
- I had a 4 6.
- I think we should switch.
- Yeah, same here.
- Okay if you want.
- You do you twins on
a switch? Or wait, no.
- Cause okay, cause
here's my thinking, right?
He had a higher GPA and he
wasn't satisfied with his score
and you had a lower GPA
and you were satisfied.
So maybe since the bars are different,
what if you guys, but this
is like trippy. This is like.
- I know you're right.
- Like what if you guys had
like exactly the same score
but cuz your bars like
your, but I don't know.
- Do you think your GPAs correlate
to your test taking abilities?
- I feel like it depends on
like the school you go to.
If you go to a school
that is not funded well
all they're trying to do is
push people out to graduate.
Like obviously you're, the
scores you get might not
reflect what you'll get on SAT.
But if you go to a school
that pours money and funding
into making sure that everyone
is getting the best education
they can get and all
that, then of course like
you might do better. If that makes sense.
But I don't think that the GPA
- Right. The person at the
school that's not well funded who
got a four five and the person
at the school that's not
well funded, who got a
three. The person who
got the four five probably
got a better SAT score. Right?
- We don't know that.
What if you, what if the woke up
on the wrong side of the bed that day?
- But we're talking about
a generalization here.
- Yeah.
- I come from a really big public school
of predominantly Hispanics
and like immigrants.
I feel like our school's
main goal was to get them
to at least graduate
because our graduation rate
is pretty low. SATs were optional.
We didn't really talk about it much.
It was a lot of kids at our school.
It, it was like, I think like 3000 or so.
So it was like one counselor
to like a hundred kids.
So if you're not showing that
you want to actually do good
in school, then we're just not
even gonna really bother you.
So
- SAT scores, like on
average across the US are
like directly proportional to
like annual household income.
Even though we can like
kind of laud it as this like
oh like perfect bureaucratic system.
It's actually not that.
And it's like very affected
by like the socioeconomic,
like inequality in the US.
- You know, you also can't
do a standardized test
on kids where they all had
vastly different like teachers
with different teaching
styles and different grading.
Like, so like.
- That's why you take a bunch of classes.
- Yeah, exactly.
So it, it does like.
- Generally I think it's kind
of a no brainer that your
GPA, for two people that went
to the same school or
similar schools, GPA would
at least be a good determining factor
of what you may have got on SAT.
- Your GPA could fluctuate.
I had a freshman and
sophomore year I had a 4.6,
junior year had a 2.4
because of stuff that was
going on with my family.
- There are some hardships that you can go
through that make your experience
with schooling a lot more difficult
than it would be if it
was just smooth sailing.
But during my time, during
the time I was taking the SAT
like, I went to rehab for four months.
I know what it's like to go
through some really hard stuff.
Yeah, there's a lot of hardships and yeah
it didn't make it easy.
But at the same time, like
hard work is hard work.
- Before COVID, I definitely
valued myself a lot
on my like GPA or like any
like school grades and stuff.
But then during COVID I realized
like there's more to life.
I valued like quality time
with my friends and family a lot more.
- Before COVID I was like really
ambitious, like I made sure
I did well in all my classes.
Like I really applied myself.
But then COVID hit and
it was my senior year
and then my freshman year in college
and I just lost like all motivation.
- Yeah. I'm with you there
where it's like as soon
as COVID hit, online school started
I just did not care about
focusing on school at all.
I like I put, opened my laptop,
joined the meeting and then I
just go get food downstairs.
- Yeah, I remember in like
the moment that it hit
it was just kind of
like, what's the point?
- Why bother?
- Yeah, yeah, exactly exactly.
How much, how much pressure
did like your family put
on you to take the SAT?
- Oh
- A lot.
- None.
- None?
- Not a lot.
- Not a lot?
- I think I had quite a lot of,
I think, cuz my family is like,
I'm a first generation
immigrant, but my parents
I feel like they're also
first generation immigrants.
So I feel like they put like
a lot of emphasis on like
like meritocracy and like
working hard to get there.
Just because like initially we didn't have
like the resources to
like do it another way.
- I am also a first generation American.
I'm Nigerian so my mom is like very like
you have to make sure that
you're doing everything right
cuz your sisters are watching after you.
Like you have to make sure you grow up
and get all these As so that
they have an example to follow.
So it was very hard
for me to kind of separate
myself from my grades because
if I did and I failed, then
I'm disappointing only my mom
but my three little sisters
- You seem like someone who's
probably a really hard worker.
- Yeah.
- And I think in that
sense you probably sh
- I feel like your
drives higher than mine.
- Yeah.
- Probably
- Breaking up the twins.
- I do gotta say I,
the way you've been talking and all that,
I feel like you have at
least a better one than me.
It's just like gut feeling kind of, but
- Oh god.
- I disagree.
- You disagree?
- Yeah.
- I'll take that as a compliment.
- I disagree too.
- Do you guys wanna lock in your answer?
Do you feel good?
- I'm so scared.
- I think we're ready.
- Yeah. Lets do it.
- I'm fine with it.
- We have Jack at 1160.
(bubble popping)
- I was really surprised I was the bottom.
I mean I didn't think I was that bad, but.
- Carla at 1170.
(bubble popping)
Michael at 1280.
Kylie at 1320.
(bubble popping)
Chichi at 1360.
Emily at 1400.
(bubble popping)
Michael at 1500.
Emily at 1600.
(video game chiming)
- What. Wow.
- Okay
- Good.
- How is someone supposed
to do better than you?
Are you sure?
Like are you working for them?
I was surprised that Emily
just didn't go forward
and put herself up front.
Like there's nobody who's
getting higher than her.
At least like impossible
- Without a calculator.
- Yeah.
- Okay. Let's talk about,
talk about this for a second.
- That's crazy.
- No, no no. Like, huh?
(static music)
- I'm going to Stanford. Okay.
- Oh, I'm gonna to USC.
- The University of Michigan.
- I also go to USC.
- Cal State Long Beach.
- I'm, I'm going to the
new school in New York.
- Well, I got accepted to Berkeley
but I'm going to community
college. It's just.
- Oh
- Yeah. Yeah.
- I go to UCSD.
Well, when I got to college
like the first two weeks
everyone was talking about
oh my God, I got like 1500, I
got a 16 like this and that.
But I don't know, I just feel
like I got in here with a 1360.
I don't think it really matters.
- As soon as I said computer science,
you guys threw me all the way up.
(everyone laughs)
Then when you look,
UCSD is like top 15 in the nation for CS.
So it just, I don't think
it reflects too much.
- I think we're at the same
intellectual capabilities again.
Like if he's not even higher,
that just made me, I was like
the SAT's, like just
not a good scale at all.
That's not an accurate
reflection of who he is.
At the end of the day, you
all got into the same school
regardless of your stats.
So like, I feel like if
you maybe lacked SAT score
you made it up for it somewhere else.
- I have to ask, when
I asked you to switch,
why did you hesitate?
- I don't, I I just don't wanna be mean.
(everyone laughs)
- Are there any final thoughts
you, you want to impart
on anyone who might be
watching this video?
- Hmm. I think the SAT is stupid.
That's, That's it. Yeah.
- Awesome. Thanks. Cut.